hey there i'm lauren ridloff and i'm
playing makari in marvel studios
eternals i'm kamel langiani and i play
kingo i'm don and i played gilgamesh i'm
liam mchugh and i play sprite and today
we're here with buzzfeed playing who's
who
who is most likely to nail a stunt on
the first try i would say angie she
really worked on the stunts a lot and i
felt like
at least for me she was on another level
she'd done so much action before this
yes i totally agree with you that was
gonna be my first thought angie she is a
preparer she really goes through
all the choreography before completing
the set and she typically gets it done
on the first try dawn
who's good at first try i gotta say leah
me yeah you were good on the first try
we we all always been doing that for a
long time so i'm so used to it but you
are the one good at first try that was
great leah who's most likely to beat a
deviant in a fight i'd say angelina yeah
fiona goddess of war i think it's dawn
because he actually is a boxer he's very
strong and do you know he's the vice
president of the south korean arm
wrestling foundation
yes
and my boys still talk about don's
biceps
like they can't believe they're real
okay but what do you think about richard
i mean he would get up and work out at 3
a.m didn't he yeah he really did work
out at 3am but you know there's a
difference between like
gym muscles which is what him and i have
and then i think
actual like fighting muscles and i think
dawn has more fighting muscles
richard and i have more wasted time in
the gym muscles who's most likely to
start laughing and break character
during a take richard maybe one time he
did that
richard gemma there was just like a
funny word that they made into a joke
when it wasn't his coverage i think he
was trying to make gemma laugh for just
like a couple times and um i think we
all started laughing at one point
i'm thinking selma oh yeah i completely
agree it is selma she laughs a lot she
has a great time on set every single day
no matter what time it is you know we'll
be shooting at 4 a.m in the middle of a
forest and somehow everybody else is
tired selma's having a great time who's
most likely to make cloisow laugh from
behind the camera kumail i gotta say
i think very very funny he was always
eating food
he's always eating in the movie too
my first thought was barry
there's just something about barry that
really gets the chloe yeah that's
exactly right there's a line well this
line is a spoiler but every time
barry said it i would see chloe laugh
every single time and it's not even a
funny line barry made chloe laugh made
me laugh too who's most likely to win a
game of marvel cinematic universe trivia
lia i think i've seen the thor movies
the most but i also really love the
avengers movies right oh my gosh it goes
we met everybody
tom hiddleston it was
like
blew my mind i i came into comic con and
they didn't tell me what it was or who
was going to be there
oh my god he should have seen my dad he
was just like
honey i'm looking at you
i am the marvel geek i want all the
movies on on blu-ray guilty is charged
listen it's hard because i love them all
but i have a special place in my heart
for
iron man because it was the first one i
love comedy i think thor ragnarok and
the guardian movies i love those movies
i've watched them so many times who is
most likely to be caught napping between
scenes listen i did nap a lot
don't you think chloe wouldn't allow
that yeah chloe didn't allow that no
napping allowed who's most likely to
pull a prank on set i think male was the
funniest people always ask the prank
question we're working how often are you
guys putting pranks at the office we
were working like pretty long days we've
been up since 5 a.m we're learning like
long complicated lines i'm just hanging
on i don't know how george clooney has
time to pull pranks on set right i don't
understand that either who's most likely
to do a spot-on impression of another
eternal's cast member maybe kumail let's
answer everything camille i feel like
camille cause he was always making jokes
and i i'm sure one time he probably
gave an impression yeah that's it i
think brian was very good at observing
people and replicating it he's not like
an impressionist but
he just really gets people what do you
think lauren
yeah i agree with you 100
who's most likely to survive on a
deserted island i think it might be dawn
again because he's just really good he's
really self-sufficient i think
gemma do you know that she
is
brilliant
with sneaking treats in her purse
because she would just have so much food
ready snacks ready that would be her
she would be able to
survive on a deserted island because
she's got her food situation down maybe
me because you know i mean
honestly i used to live in montana and
then i was hunting i went out hunting
every day so i'm really good at it so
she's the most prepared yeah and finally
who's most likely to give the best life
advice salma she makes everybody around
her happy she really did yeah it was
definitely selma selma gave me a lot of
advice that was all very very helpful
like personal advice marriage advice
uh career advice she's just full of
wisdom
yeah i agree with you it's definitely
selma there is a reason why she was
chosen to play ajak
she is the matriarch of the eternals
thank you so much buzzfeed please do not
forget eternals in theaters november 5th
go watch please thank you
you